verfügten stunde ich hasse fliegen mann
ist ab tausend dinge an diesen und muss
pünktlich sein und ich kann mich
pünktlich sein
ab geht's
nach berlin fliege ich glaube ich
mit
seitdem muss noch durch noch ich bin in
berlin gelandet und zwar fragt ihr euch
bestimmt warum es ist luca berlin
ihr könnt ja wahrscheinlich dass mobile
games angry birds und zwar bringt sony
jetzt auch zu dem spiel angry birds noch
einen kinofilm raus ihr seht es bis auf
das mächtige nicht in seinen mund
spucken
oh mann
furchtbare wendung der ereignisse
furchtbar das beste ist sie hat mich
gefragt ob ich lust hätte eine synchrone
rolle einzunehmen also quasi zu sprechen
wie ein vogel und ich bin dann ein vogel
ich bin ich schon vogel freut ihr euch
auf den angry birds film
wir auch wollt ihr euch auf den
engelbertz film wollt ihr euch falls ihr
euch freut ihr euch auf den enkel bin
ich freue mich dass ich freue mich
darauf freu mich auf den film bei dem
kino zwölfte fünfter du auch
habe ich um
wir sind alle kommunikations studio ich
sehe und star trek quote gemacht
hier wurde kunst man da alles youtube
wurde
so sieht das hier auf jeden fall raus
ich dir jetzt hier in synchronisation
stumpf und stelle mich jetzt quasi
hinter das mikrofon und wird jetzt
sprechen gottes die kamera schwer alter
also gar nicht sagt er auf englisch
das ist quasi das ja wahnsinn
wie heißt du herr du stehst darauf
schräge sachen oder naja mal bei regen
musste ja dann mit ihm
er schafft es das ist ja unglaublich das
geht in die geschichte ein
haben wir gewonnen nein noch nicht ganz
kumpel steht nach unentschieden hey holt
jemand ein eisbeutel verhält
wir sind jetzt fertig mit den
synchronisations arbeiten ich habe ja
ein bisschen was gelagert was genau das
sein wird erfahrt ihr am 12.5 und wir
machen uns jetzt auf dem rückweg ich
sehe hier gerade was da läuft aber ihr
dürft das noch nicht sehen ich bin jetzt
wieder draußen wieder zum auto zurück
nach hause
hallo ich bin gerade wieder zu hause
haltet das fischfleisch nicht richtig
ich nutze das ja nie so wirklich ich
komme aber auch nicht auf dieses fischer
klar
unfassbar wie ich wollte jetzt nochmal
zum abschluss machen weil ich wirklich
im flieger eingeteilt bin und danach
auch total fertig war bewusst dass ich
noch sagen sollte
ich musste das ganze video als
werbevideo kennzeichnen lassen seht ihr
die ganze drum eingeblendet weitläufigen
der engelbert sache nach berlin geflogen
bin und ich auch den trailer gezeigt
habe und so deswegen ist einfach eine
rechtliche sache findet weitere infos
bezüglich trailer kinostart cetera
nochmal unten in der beschreibung
aufgelistet genauso wie meine netzwerk
etc
die premiere von dem film ist am ersten
mal in berlin da werde ich auch mit am
start seinen irgendeinem kino wenn ihr
googelt findet ihr das bestimmt könnt
ihr mich vielleicht sogar treffen ich
freue mich auf jeden fall schon runter
auf den film weil ich ja quasi ein
kleiner teil davon bin weil ich ja diese
heldin und gut mehr vielleicht einfacher
fallen dann würde ich mich über die
bewertungen freuen und wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder rein als jetzt